[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour écoutez c'est un grand plaisir
pour moi d'être parmi vous et devant
vous ce soir pour vous présenter un
parcours le mien entre parenthèses d'un
jeune d'un jeune de province qui qui a
voulu trouver un métier qui savait pas
du tout quoi faire et puis qu'est-ce qui
est arrivé un jour il a fait des extras
pour payer sa mobylette dans un
restaurant à faire la plonge et j'ai
fait la planche pendant quelques mois et
puis de là le patron m'a dit ben voilà
je cherche un apprenti en septembre
est-ce que tu veux pas rester la place
est libre j'ai personne je dis oui
pourquoi pas voilà donc le restaurant je
connaissais pas j'avais quasiment jamais
été avec mes parents ont été pas trop
aller dans ces endroits là on
connaissait pas et j'ai découvert un
milieu complètement différent un milieu
où on vit différemment un milieu où les
gens ont une vie qui est un peu à côté
de celle des autres et c'est ça qui m'a
beaucoup plu justement ne pas être comme
les autres de faire quelque chose de
différent qu'est-ce il faut il faut être
exigeant avec soi-même mais pas trop non
plus il faut vraiment être persuadé
qu'on veut réussir quelque chose il faut
être persuadé
qu'on va oser faire des défis et ça
c'est important quand on est très jeune
il faut pas écouter ceux qui veulent
rester pantouflard et autres c'est pas
bon il faut vraiment
oser y aller et surtout surtout
respectez les gens autour de soi ça a
été les trois choses fondamentales que
j'ai eu quand j'ai été jeune et qui
m'ont permis d'évoluer qui m'ont permis
de gravir les échelons après moi
l'apprentissage j'ai été à Carlton de
Cannes alors bien sûr quand vous arrivez
de province et à Cannes où il y a du
film et tout c'est le jour et la nuit
bien sûr dans une grande entreprise où
il y avait 60 personnes dans le service
de cuisine donc moi on travaille à trois
ou quatre mais c'était complètement
différent je m'ennuyais un petit peu
parce que je travaillais moins qu'avant
j'avais l'impression de travailler un
peu moins qu'avant mais très structuré
très organisé deuxième commis premier
commis chez le parti sous chef comme à
l'armée voilà très organisée il fallait
marcher ou pas voilà c'était comme ça
j'ai appris énormément de choses avec
des gens qui avaient 40 ans de carrière
je me rappelle j'avais des gens des
chaînes de parties qui avec moi avait
plus de 60 ans 65 ans pour certains qui
avaient connu alors j'étais en 69 qui
avait connu la guerre voilà donc oui
c'était un autre avec des méthodes de
sécurité avec les méthodes de peut-être
qu'on va manquer demain vous voyez un
autre horizon d'autres gens et puis des
jeunes qui arrivaient toute la France
pour faire cette saison au Carlton de
Cannes c'était quand même très bel
établissement où j'ai passé cinq années
cinq années merveilleuse mais j'avais un
petit problème je vous ai dit dyslexie
difficile d'apprendre à l'école je
savais pas très bien lire et pas très
bien écrire donc à 20 ans j'ai repris
l'école j'ai repris l'école des cours de
français de mathématiques pourront
remettre à niveau pas pour avoir bac + 2
ou 4 c'était complètement illusoire tout
ça mais au moins de bien savoir écrire
et lire ça c'était important et j'ai je
l'ai fait c'est pas facile croyez moi
c'est très dur et puis dans cette ville
de Cannes avec Nice à côté avec beaucoup
de gens très important dans la
profession des grands chefs sur la Côte
d'Azur il y avait aussi des concours des
concours à la cuisine artistique la
cuisine artistique c'est
des thèmes qui vous sont demandés et
vous faites des prouesses avec des
présentations là vous voyez il y a un
plat en bas voilà hiver
la chlorophylle c'est sur la vie
d'Escoffier donc il y a des petits
médaillons en fil de truffe et ce plat
m'a demandé environ 500 heures de
travail c'est des défis que vous mettez
sur la tête vous dire mais est-ce que je
vais être capable de faire ça est-ce que
j'aurais la force d'aller jusqu'au bout
alors quand on veut faire de la
compétition professionnelle ou sportive
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire il faut pas
fumer faut pas boire pour prendre soin
de son corps il faut être très résistant
donc il faut déjà être bien dans son
corps et puis après bien être dans sa
tête parce que dans sa tête le mental le
moral c'est vraiment primordial c'est
45% de réussite donc tout ça fait que
j'ai fait beaucoup d'expositions de
plats d'expédition des sculptures des
grandes pièces en glaces également qui
me passionnaient aussi et du carbone je
suis allé au à Paris parce que j'étais
au compagnonnage j'étais reçu compagnon
j'avais 25 ans et à Paris je suis arrivé
à l'Intercontinental une boîte
américaine qui s'était les hôtels de la
Paname à l'époque et donc en 76 on
faisait déjà les ratios les flux de
cosse les choses comme ça chose qu'on
connaissait pas du tout dans la
restauration et dans les services de
cuisine on a été très loin de ça la
gestion pure et dure 5 voilà je l'ai
appris très tôt et ça ça m'a beaucoup
avantagé ça m'a permis de devenir cadre
très jeune parce que j'ai su gérer des
services des achats des organisations
très jeunes et
ça m'a donné le bénéfice de pouvoir
avoir des postes de cadre assez jeune
également je faisais toujours des plats
d'expédition ça m'a pris 20 ans de ma
vie la cuisine artistique entre les
plats pour les expos les pièces en
beurre les éléphants presque à taille
réelle pour des grandes sociétés enfin
les logos d'entreprise voilà tas de
choses énormes où on faisait des pièces
particulières et là mon travail c'était
de faire ces pièces pour les pour
l'événementiel tout simplement j'en ai
fait beaucoup et ça m'a fait connaître
le le circuit si vous voulez des
concours d'exposition a fait que j'ai
rencontré des gens
que je n'aurais peut-être jamais connu
si j'avais pas fait de compétition
professionnelle et ces gens là et bien
ils m'ont repéré j'ai même quand j'étais
au Grand Palais en 4e j'avais gagné un
concours le président de tous les
concours qui était guillaugué qui était
le chef du Doyen à l'époque m'a dit ben
voilà je vous allez venir avec moi
dans mon nouvel équipier parce que je
vais faire une nouvelle équipe mais je
peux pas vous dire où vous savez quand
vous avez 25 ans c'est pas grave ce soir
judicieux en France et lui c'est en
France pas de problème et puis
j'apprends dans les journaux quelques
jours après que c'était à l'hôtellerie
qui reprenait les reines de l'hôtellerie
qui avait changé de propriétaire et puis
j'ai dit au chef du côté j'arrive de la
Côte d'Azur j'ai plein de copains encore
là-bas qu'est-ce que je veux s'y
retourner parce que j'aime beaucoup ce
pays c'est vrai que c'est un pays
merveilleux on prend des habitudes alors
c'est vrai que il faut pas rester trop
pantouflard qu'on a un peu trop
d'habitude et bon on n'ose pas trop le
moment faire les choses on ose moins et
ça c'est pas bon
donc il y a pas de problème et puis je
suis resté 32 ans dans cette entreprise
je suis devenu chef de cuisine bien sûr
avec quelques années après j'ai passé
mon concours de Meilleur Ouvrier de
France et j'étais toujours dans le
compagnonnage où je faisais bien sûr des
actions pour les jeunes ceux qui
arrivent à Paris etc donc oui c'est une
belle carrière mais si vous voulez
ce qui a motivé ma carrière ce qui a
motivé absolument tout ce que j'ai pu
faire c'est les gens autour de moi avoir
des gens qui travaillent autour de vous
qui profite pas de vous mais qui font
qui font vraiment le coeur avec vous
c'est important on réussit pas tout seul
il faut avoir des gens autour de soi des
gens qui vous aiment bien des gens qui
ont eu des capacités des gens qui vont
vous aider pour des détails et des
petites choses mais qui vont vous faire
gagner du temps des gens à qui vous
pouvez parler vous pouvez dire vos états
d'âmes etc ça c'est vraiment très
important donc on réussit pas tout seul
dans la vie il faut avoir des gens
autour de soi qu'on estime qu'on
respecte pour différentes raisons des
gens aux apporter des techniques de
travail d'autres une très grande amitié
dont on voit un secours quand vous avez
des difficultés personnelles etc etc
c'est important d'avoir du monde autour
de soi et c'est pour ça que dans tous
les services où j'ai travaillé j'ai
voulu toujours l'esprit d'équipe c'est
extrêmement important
on respectait les gens on travaillait
beaucoup s'il y avait une commande ou un
quelque chose de dernière minute vous
fallait travailler peut-être toute la
nuit je demandais à quelques-uns il dit
oui tout le temps parce qu'ils savaient
que il le faisait pas pour rien il
savait qu'on les respectait et il
faisait par amitié pour nous également
et ça c'est important dans le travail
partagez sa vie la vie dans le travail
vous y passez peut-être le plus long
moment de votre vie alors autant que ça
se passe bien alors je sais qu'il y a
des chefs qui
sont pas
très élégants sont un peu coléreux et
autres non c'est pas bon quand vous les
tirer le maximum de profit des jeunes
gens
c'est de voir leur confiance c'est de
les respecter c'est de le transmettre
votre savoir leur dire leur expliquer
qu'ils sont là pour apprendre quelque
chose ils vont en faire leur fonds de
commerce personnel ça va leur donner une
valeur à eux pour plus tard et quand ils
ont compris ça ils travaillent avec vous
et quelquefois faut même les envoyer un
peu ailleurs qui boient d'autres
horizons pour s'améliorer c'est ça le
respect des gens et j'ai voulu passer ça
dans l'esprit du meilleur apprenti de
France ce concours des Meilleurs
Apprentis France c'est 6000 jeunes
parents qui concourent tous les ans dans
120 métiers différents avec 4000
bénévoles autour et ces jeunes là ils
commencent la compétition
professionnelle c'est des jeunes de
moins de 21 ans qui ont commencé leur
formation des fois à 15-16 ans et qui
vont se lancer dans les concours et
c'est là que c'est important pour leur
vie professionnelle c'est de commencer à
la compétition très jeune et de là
quand vous avez des meilleures apprentis
de France et dire des jeunes qui ont été
triés déjà par département région et
nationale vous savez que c'est des gens
qui ont une mentalité particulière qui
veulent réussir
87% de ces jeunes là veulent créer leur
entreprise aujourd'hui donc vous voyez
on dit les jeunes machins et autres moi
je veux bien mais moi j'en connais plein
ils sont super bon et ça dans plein de
milieux différents alors qu'on parle des
bons ça serait bien et puis que les
brûleurs de voitures qu'on les oublie
c'est pas ça va pas nous manquer
je voulais vous donner un exemple je le
petit Moussa qui que vous voyez sur la
photo un jeune émigré qui est arrivé en
France il y a 3 ans
parlez pas le français il est venu dans
différents pays d'Afrique et après
l'Espagne la France après c'était un
jeune garçon recueilli par la
Croix-Rouge il a été en formation
d'apprentissage son rêve c'était des
footballeurs mais c'est difficile
d'arriver footballeur à Paris quand on
l'étranger son papier et autres c'est
pas facile donc on lui a proposé une
formation de primeur primeur vous savez
c'est ceux qui font les belles
corbeilles de fruits préparations de
fruits et les corbeilles etc et il a
apprécié ce métier et ils sont maître
d'apprentissage que vous voyez sur la
photo monsieur Fabre l'inscrit au
concours meilleur apprenti de France il
est devenu meilleur apprenti de France
grâce à cela il a eu ses papiers parce
que quand on a des jeunes qui
réussissent en France je pense qu'il
faut mieux les garder que les envoyer
ailleurs et je pense que ça c'est une
leçon d'intégration extraordinaire donc
on a plein de jeux et c'est pas un cas
isolé j'en ai environ dizaines par an
dans plein de métiers différents donc
c'est la transmission du savoir qui est
importante chez quelqu'un et on se doit
quand on est un bon professionnel on se
doit de
transmettre son savoir c'est vraiment
très très important on n'a pas une belle
vie professionnelle si on n'a pas su
donner ce qu'on a reçu ce que vous
donnez à ce jeune qui lui-même va
rajouter ce qu'il va apprendre avec
d'autres et ainsi de suite dire qu'on a
un complément de formation qui se fait
avec les générations qui suivent et ça
c'est important parce que ce que vous
avez appris ce que vous avez transmis il
y a forcément des centaines de personnes
qui m'ont refaire derrière vous et ce
que vous avez trouvé parce qu'on trouve
des fois des méthodes des certains
styles de travail et bien c'est pas
perdu ça sert à quelque chose ça sert à
bâtir l'avenir professionnel et l'avenir
de nos métiers
voilà un peu la vie que l'on peut avoir
dans une profession alors dans la vie il
faut oser c'est important il faut
prendre sur soi beaucoup de choses je
pense pas qu'il faut se donner toujours
corps et âme au triste
des bénéfices de
détruire il faut garder quand même une
partie où on doit être un homme ou une
femme comme tout le monde mais avoir
cette possibilité de dire je veux
réussir quelque chose tous les gens qui
ont réussi c'est parce qu'ils ont
travaillé beaucoup on ne réussit pas si
on ne travaille pas on ne réussit pas si
on passe pas beaucoup de temps
des fois dans sa tête à réfléchir à
travailler pour construire quelque chose
quand on a une idée il faut aller
jusqu'au bout faut pas s'arrêter en
honte
faut pas rester pantouflard parce que
vos rêves que vous avez eu si vous les
faites pas vous allez arriver à un âge
où vous pourrez plus le faire et vous
allez regretter toutes vos vies que vous
avez raté quelque chose et ça je crois
c'est ce qu'il y a de plus triste dans
une vie alors le conseil qu'on peut
donner aux et tous vos rêves aller à
fond dans ce que vous voulez faire
n'écoutez pas ceux qui veulent vous
ralentir ce qu'ils le font qui veut le
ralentir c'est parce que ils sont
peut-être jaloux de l'idée que vous avez
eu et que l'ont pas eu tout simplement
donc il faut foncer il faut trouver tous
les moyens pour réussir
faites-vous des relations choisissez vos
relations essayez de trouver des gens
qui ont des compétences des gens qui
vont vous apporter de la confiance de la
connaissance ça c'est vraiment important
et quand on ose toute sa vie on réussit
forcément
tous les gens tous les grands chefs que
j'ai connu que je connais encore qui ont
réussi c'est pas forcément des jeunes
gens de la haute bourgeoisie c'est
souvent des jeunes gens qui ont lu des
difficultés enfants ils sont arrivés
dans ce métier parce que il y avait une
place voilà c'est pas forcément par rêve
d'enfant quelques-uns mais très peu mais
c'est parce qu'ils ont trouvé une force
en eux pour aller jusqu'au bout de leurs
rêves et ça c'est la chose importante à
faire dans sa vie alors si vous avez des
jeunes gens autour de vous qui savent
pas trop quoi faire de leur vie surtout
qui regardent un petit peu les métiers
on peut aller voir quelqu'un qui
travaille du cuir du bois du fer et
autres et quand on voit les gestes
manuels de quelqu'un qui crée quelque
chose avec des manières très différentes
ça va forcément vous donner des idées
peut-être de faire ce métier peut-être
d'en faire un autre qui est avoisinant
mais de faire quelque chose avec son
cerveau et ses mains si vous n'êtes pas
bon à l'école c'est pas bien grave le
sait que j'en parle pas ils sont tous
super mais ceux qui ont des difficultés
à l'école on a toute la vie pour
apprendre il y a pas plus belle
géographie que de voyager avant 30 ans
dans le monde entier de découvrir des
paysages des couverts des nouveaux
peuples etc etc et ça c'est votre
culture personnelle
on va à l'école de telle année de
naissance à tel année non c'est pas vrai
vous avez toute la vie pour aller à
l'école vous avez toute la vie pour vous
former et c'est ça sa culture
l'importance que l'on a chacun avoir une
culture générale personnelle et ça on
l'a fait avec le travail avec l'après
travail et surtout dans le respect des
gens ça je crois que aujourd'hui le
monde du travail a certainement des
difficultés il y en a qui ont été
certainement trop loin il faut repenser
le travail le redistribuer mais sachez
que si l'on veut réussir il faut
travailler beaucoup c'est indispensable
la réussite allait le fruit d'efforts
personnel de recherche personnelle et
aussi de travail acharné et quand on a
réussi quelque chose dans sa vie je
pense qu'on peut être heureux on peut
transmettre ça ses enfants et ses
petits-enfants mesdames messieurs merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]